what's going on guys national master
james canton iii here with chess.com
and today we have the top five blunders
yes the best in the world still blunders
sometimes
the top five blunders and the speed
chess championships
this first game is actually cargo
nakamura versus magnus carlson back in
in the speedchest championship let's see
what happens here so icaru actually is
uh under some fire here his queen
is attacked as we see here he has double
rooks on the file
the c5 pawn is actually hit but his
queen is the immediate piece that he has
to move right now
so where do you think you would move
your queen here why to move what do you
actually do
here we go this is what car would chose
queen of four
get out of the way right i'm fine i have
some moves okay maybe queen h4 could be
a thing
maybe even back up to queen f3 if i have
to but queen f4 but now you have to
notice that
the queen is short on spaces when you
see a queen short on spaces like here
here here
here you don't have any squares to
really go to maybe this one
what do we do you attack it g5
the game's over already and he resigns
in this position
can you believe it guys very very easy
queen f5 the queen's attacked
queen f4 and g5 and the queen is trapped
and this was example number one now
let's move on
to example number two now in this next
example we have alexander grishik with
white pieces
versus magnus carlsen with the black
pieces back in 2016.
let's actually see what happened here so
if you see this position right here
black or magnus is actually giving some
problems down here
on the back rank the king is slightly
safe but things like f4 maybe we could
do this
there's some things that's happening for
both sides of the board here actually
there's a pass pawn coming too
so you have to be active you have to do
something so magnus chose f4 here which
is a very strong move here bishop takes
h3 is the immediate threat
followed by queen takes f1 so either
pawn capture would be bishop takes h3
so actually alexander grisham chose
queen two h4 here
after queen h4 he's just saying hey look
you can't take on h3
you're i'm totally fine if you play f3
i'm actually just gonna probably back up
king to g1
and then if if uh king g1 and bishop
takes c4
which is actually pinning then we have
queen takes e4 check followed by queen
takes
c4 but what happens here is he doesn't
realize he has blundered
he has blundered the game is over after
this next move
can you find it
the game is over guys if you chose g5
whoa you are thinking just like magnus
this is a blunder g5 the game's over
and he resigns as the queen is trapped
has no squares to go to
the light squares are covered by the
dark square queen here or the dark queen
here the black queen
and queen g4 you can't play here obvious
reasons bishop takes
and that's it the queen has nowhere else
to go so he resigns in this position
a blunder guys it does happen to the
best of us
now let's move on to example number
three and here we are guys with example
number three or should we say blunder
number three in this game we have hikaru
nakamura with the white pieces
versus the world champion magnus carlson
this was in 2018
let's see what's going on on the board
here now it's black to move here black
has some choices to make magnus has some
things to do he has a very active rook
here
that could help maybe in some cases of
rook to g5 bishop h3s
but we have to figure out what we do
what we're doing here and this rook is
kind of weird here on e5 but it could
help us
but magnus actually chose a move here
there was an immediate blunder that
ended the game on the spot here he
actually chose can you believe it guys
d take c4 seems like a simple move here
we actually may follow up with rook to
d5 you can't take this way
you would have to take with the pawn
followed by maybe bishop f5 we put some
pressure
onto this bishop because the queen's
pinned or is the queen pinned white to
move guys have you done your tactics
today
what would you play here in this
position
why to move can you believe it guys
bishop takes eight seven
oh my goodness a regular tactic here
something that the world champion even
fell for half man
have everything else it's okay sometimes
they blunder too
but here it definitely hurt bishop takes
h7 check
followed by king takes or knight takes
no matter which piece you take with and
we're taking the queen and hikaru
nakamura wins on the spot as magnus
resigns
in this position from a blunder
now let's move on to example number four
all right guys and here we go
for example number four this is
alexander grishik with the white pieces
playing against magnus carlsen in 2017.
let's actually see what's going on on
the board here white is doing some scary
things to the king here there's making
two
threats everywhere i mean these past
pawns look very scary here
and it's black to move so magnet just
says hey we gotta check you
we have to do something here and he
actually chose a very nice check because
there's very limited moves here guys you
have to you have to
like be aware of what's going on you
have to probably go king h4
because of king 2h5 then there's mate on
h3
and it king to f5 well then we actually
check here and after king
to e5 we have queen to g3 followed by
skewering the king and the queen here
nice skewer
so but the move actually chosen was
queen to g3 by grishak here
but this is a blunder queen g3 how is it
a blunder
how is it a blunder can you actually see
why this is a blunder guys black to move
here it is guys it's just taking the
queen
it's just taking the queen guys
literally just taking the queen
because he blunders into now a losing
ending what do you mean losing
it looks like white's crushing here well
let's watch the rest of it
a5 this is now a losing end game for
white this is not even a draw after c5
because he has to get the pawns rolling
you have to do something here king e7
and surprisingly
this king can stop the pawns what are
you serious absolutely
the king can absolutely stop all three
of these pawns if you push this one i
take this one
if you push this one then i'll take and
then i'll take this one and i'll be able
to get back when you want to run this
one
so let's see what he does king f4 a4
that pawn's running king a5 a3 pass
pawns must be pushed
then we have d6 check he just backs up
it's nothing to it you push this one i
step up
you push the other one i step in king d7
and this pawn helps me a lot luckily
this pawn
is here on b7 to actually hold here now
after king to d7
there's king to d5 and a2 and he resigns
in this position because there's nothing
to do there is nothing to do you can't
stop the queen at this point
unbelievable guys unbelievable if you
actually look at this position right
here you would never
think that white could lose this
position but you actually clan it
you actually can it was a bl it was a
blunder here queen to g3
seems like it's the only move you
actually have king h4 but queen to g3
captures going into a losing ending guys
unbelievable this is why you should
study your end games and even
the best of the best fail and blunder as
well
as we see here this very nice fashion
here we're going to queen and the game
is completely over guys this was
100 a blunder very very sneaky blunder
to say the least book magnus was able to
find and convert this game
and that was example number four blunder
number four now we move on to the final
example now in this final example guys
this final blunder
we have hikaru nakamura versus sergey
gregorians
now in this position actually this was
back in 2017 here
um we actually have black to move here
so this bishop's hanging
but also he could capture first and
that's actually what he chose he said
rick takes d1 but he actually missed an
in-between move guys and in between
origins
he missed the in-between move that
actually costs him the game rook takes
d1 is just
a blunder why why is it a blunder guys
pretty self-explanatory let's see if you
can find it
here it is knight takes c5 with check
with
check now you have to go towards the
king towards the knight here
because if you don't play king e7 or f6
we just take the rook
and this is easy like let's just start a
new game i'm already up a piece here why
are we still playing this game
king to d6 he has to go towards the
knight here so he can capture it
but we actually have another in between
move knight takes b7 check
thank you for the pawn and after king to
c7 rook takes
and then after you take here's another
pawn thank you so much for the pawn here
and now we go into a winning ending but
it does take
technique so let's see his technique
rick f6 just absolutely uh threatening
both of the pawns here keeping the king
kinda at bay
rook to b8 and we actually choose a very
sharp move here as he
always finds rook to e6 a threatening
rook takes c5 check
really grabbing this pawn so we can grab
this one as well and have a a
central pass pawn ready to go rook to b3
and then rook takes c5
king to c4 take the other one now we
have a central pass pawn
and another pass pawn he didn't even
bother these guys sometimes you don't
even need to bother the other pawns
it's just hey where can i create the
fastest pass pawns and go with it rick
takes c3
we bring the rook to the back rank here
we're gonna push and we're gonna push
you can't stop both
c5 he tries to push his own then we have
a5 rook a3
a6 king d4 a7 threatening check
either way you can't do anything you
need to shelter your king so he does
king c3 no checks
and then he plays e5 c4 uh in e6 and
then rook
to a6 and after uh he's threatening to
take with check
actually so then king to f1 he moves out
of the way and there's no way to stop
everything
if rook takes we just move our rook out
of the way because this rook was doing a
good job of defending and if you do
nothing i'm just going to push this pawn
and then if you're trying to push yours
i'm actually queening before you even
get close
and then the game's over from there so
he resigned in this position guys
now imagine this of course this doesn't
look as scary as you think it is
but after rook takes d1 knight takes c5
that in between move guys make sure you
look for the
checks and captures and in between moves
digits and jugs that may happen
in your own games and this was a blunder
here by one of the best knight takes c5
king to d6
and hikaru wins in great fashion after
two in-between moves
to finish off the game to get a winning
in-game
from here guys winning in-game and he
won
in great fashion and this was the top
five blunders guys even the best of the
best the half man
have everything else's that we have here
in uh our chess world
they blundered two as well this was the
top five blunders i'm national master
james canty the third and i'll see you
guys
on the next video